de l'effort physique de l'humiliation
quelques défis le bizutage a longtemps
été incontournable pour accueillir les
nouvelles recrues dans bien des écoles
les bleus étaient de la rue victimes
si peu est tellement consentante et
héros surtout du rite initiatique
le passage est obligatoire mais qu'en
pensent les étudiants 1964 sa vue et une
semaine après gens très sympathiques
avec nous une gêne 18h des bandes pas
d'esprit solidarité enfin moi je pense
pas il y assure tous ceux qui ne se
raconte pas devant les caméras
dans cette même école le directeur ne
semble pas ignorer les pratiques de ses
étudiants il y a des tendances chez
certains on veut dire des sévices à des
brimades des humiliations à des annonces
c'est en 1991 que la loi du silence se
brise avec les premiers morts officiels
dans ce document des images filmées par
des étudiants montre la violence
corporelle l'humiliation
la nudité et cela peut aller très long
ils ont arrosé d'un colorant qui j'avais
dîné dans l'alcool à brûler pour que
soit disant le colorant tiennent mieux
qu'on ait plus de mal à le retirer
puis phase a priori indépendante de la
première ils ont approché une bougie
pour simuler le marquage au fer rouge
j'ai été brûlé aux 1er 2e 3e degré selon
les endroits
survint la concentration aurel c'est
dans ce contexte de violences extrêmes
que ségolène royal se donne pour mission
d' arrêter cette violence on arrivera
assez vite à l'éradiquer parce que le
jour où les auteurs de violence se
rendront compte qu'ils ne bénéficient
plus de l'impunité dont ils
bénéficiaient jusqu'à présent ça sera
terminé depuis 1998 une loi interdit le
bizutage
les auteurs encourent six mois de prison
et 7500 euros damende pour autant ce
n'est pas la fin du phénomène
c'est ce qu'explique en 2007 ce
professeur engagée dans la lutte contre
le bizutage la loi de 98 a certainement
changer les choses mais a poussé la
discrétion plus qu'autre chose avant
c'était plus voyants c'est au jardin du
luxembourg c'était au château de
versailles
là ce n'est plus ce n'est plus à ces
endroits là
c'est plus caché plus cacher parfois
sous le nom de week-ends d'intégration
ces événements organisés pour l'accueil
de nouveaux étudiants sont à chaque
rentrée le lieu de drame
la consommation d'alcool y est parfois
excessives à l'origine de plusieurs
décès chaque année
quant aux suites judiciaires elles sont
rares le silence pèse encore lourd dans
le milieu étudiant
[Musique]